Today we are going to create absolutely incredible
virtual worlds with these new papers. First,
NVIDIA did something here, but if the quality
does not seem to be too much better here,
then how does this really
help? We’ll find out together.
Then, we are going to re-sculpt an image
with this collaboration between
Intel and New York University.
Then, we will become a movie
director and give directions to,
not people, but get this: images. Oh yes.
And then, we won’t even need
to direct these images. This
AI technique directs the video by itself.
Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
So, with NERFs, we are able to gather a bunch of
photos, and have a technique stitch it together
into a virtual world. There are models that
can do this extremely quickly, for instance,
Instant Neural Graphics. This converges in a
matter of seconds, which is kind of insane.
And its quality is often even better than its
predecessors. You see a great deal more detail
in the hair and the sweater. And now, let’s
see the new technique! Ready to be blown away.
Wait a second… this looks nearly the same!
So is this better? If it is better, how?
Well, what you see here is quality, but quality
is just half of the story! The other half is
size. We haven’t talked about that yet.
The first technique is reasonably sized,
but the quality is lacking, then comes
Instant Neural Graphics, quality much better,
but the size is much larger. And now, look at
the new technique, which looks roughly the same,
but, oh my, it packs the same quality but in one
fifth the size. Fantastic. In this sense, this is
even better than the legendary new technique,
Gaussian Splatting, which can create and now,
even animate virtual worlds, and this new one
is 50 times more compact than that. Crazy.
Now, let’s sculpt some images. Second paper.
Here, the goal is to take an image, any image,
and then, convert the people or objects in
it into a 3D model, but not to create a video
game character from them, although that’s quite
nice too, but no, not here! Here, we now have
knowledge about the backside of this model too,
so we can choose a new pose for our character,
and apply some more magic to put it back into the
image with the new pose. We can even rotate them,
you name it. Shifting these objects to
new positions is also possible. And wait,
these are 3D models, so we can even apply
deformations to them. Carve out that bad boy,
and there we go! Apart from some
suspect artifacts at the mouth region,
this one is almost perfect. Or placing
new ducklings or fish into an image?
Not a problem. And this concept gives us a great
deal of control over these images. For instance,
how many cherries would you like? How about
this one? And another one? And another one? The
consistency between the images is not perfect, but
they are nearly the same. And just imagine what
we will be capable of just two more papers down
the line. My goodness. What a time to be alive!
And, we are not done with magic for today,
not even close. With this other work,
we can apply some more artistic direction to
already existing images. Just look at the arrows,
this indicates our wishes as to how the image
should be moving, and bam! We get a video. This
works great for camera movement, but you know
what. I wonder what happens if I instruct this
horse to move. That is so much more complex than
just camera movement. So, what happens then? Now
hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars, and…my
goodness. Look at that. The AI understands how a
horse should move, and synthesizes exactly that.
It is not perfect, not even close, but this is
once again an excellent opportunity to invoke
the First Law of Papers. What is that? Well,
the First Law of Papers says that research
is a process. Do not look at where we are,
look at where we will be two more papers down
the line. Remember what DALL-E 1 could do in
terms of text to image, and then, DALL-E 2
dropped and blew it out of the water. Just
imagine what a DALL-E 2 moment for this
kind of video synthesis could be. Wow.
And now, check this out. Here, this AI technique
looked at videos of people in real conversations,
and then, all we need is our audio input.
Then, get this, it creates virtual characters,
mouth movements and even gestures automatically
so we can have conversations in virtual worlds
more easily. I have to say the synthesized
movements are often expressive, I give you
that, but also sometimes a little stiff,
mouth movement is not that accurate yet,
but it is very impressive that from just the
audio, all this can be synthesized. Once again,
just two more papers down the line, and you might
start seeing this out there in the real world.
I think this work is a really good showcase of how
difficult this problem is. You see, our brains are
wired to look at each other, and read each other’s
expressions. Thus, if even a little hesitation,
just a tiny smirk, if just the slightest things
are off, we immediately know that something is
wrong. We are wired for that. So making this
work properly will be incredibly difficult,
but if something, human ingenuity and
the power of AI will be able to do that.